THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WIT
US TONIGHT.
LET'S TURN TO ANOTHER MAJOR
CRISIS CAUSED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IN MAY, BORDER PATROL TALLIED A
RECORD NUMBER OF MIGRANTS AND
COUNTERS, 239,000 AND JUST ONE
MONTH ALONE CARRIED THIS
SITUATION IS SO DIRE THAT
MULTIPLE TEXAS COUNTIES, LISTEN
TO THIS, HAVE NOW DECLARED THIS
CRISIS AND INVASION.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE IS FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARAH CARTER
ALONG WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
BRANDON JUDGE.
NOW WHAT WE'VE GOT, BRANDON, WE
WILL START WITH YOU IS THAT BY
DECLARING IT AND INVASION.
SEVERAL OF THESE COUNTIES IN
TEXAS, AND THEY BELIEVE IN
ARIZONA AS WELL, BELIEVE THAT
UNDER THEIR CONSTITUTION, THAT
THE CLEARING AND INVASION ALLOW
FOR THE STATES TO THEN ENGAGE I
A SITUATION WHERE WITHOUT THE
APPROVAL OF CONGRESS, THEY CAN
TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
ACTUALLY HANDLE THOSE IMMIGRANT
AND RETURN THEM TO MEXICO.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> THIS CLEARLY HOW BAD THE
STATES FEEL RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
THE CRISIS GOES.
THESE COUNTIES ARE NOT
REPUBLICAN COUNTIES.
THEY CLEARLY KNOW THAT THEY ARE
SHOULDERING THE BURDEN OF
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING ON AS
FAR AS ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DOES.
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE DRUG
COMING AND IT'S NOT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, IT'S A COUNTIES.
THEY KNOW THAT THIS SITUATION
CAN BE CONTROLLED, BUT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE THE WHITE HOUSE
SUPPORT TO GET IT DONE AND THE
WHITE HOUSE ISN'T DOING ANYTHIN
ABOUT IT.
SO THE STATES NOW HAVE TO STEP
IN.
THEY'RE HAVING TO LOOK AT HOW
THEY CAN EXPEDITE THEIR
AUTHORITY UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
.
I'M HOPING THE STATES ARE
WILLING TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN AND LET IT GO TO THE COURTS
LET THE COURTS DETERMINE WHETHE
THOSE STATES CAN INFECT YOU THIS
.
AS LONG AS THEY DO IT THEY CAN
IT WILL SHUN DESPITE LOT ON WHA
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
TO GET YOU TO GIVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SOME CREDIT FOR THIS.
HE READ THE STATE CONSTITUTION
AND HE READ IT AS OPENING UP A
NUMBER OF POTENTIAL LEGAL
AVENUES THAT CAN BE ROLLED ON B
THE COURTS.
SARAH CARTER, YOU HAVE BEEN AT
THE BORDER FOR YEARS I HAVE
VISITED THE BORDER MANY TIMES
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
BORDER DURING JOE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION COMPARED TO OTHE
ADMINISTRATIONS?
IT'S RUN WITH IMPUNITY AS FAR A
WORLD DEALING WITH THE DRUG
CARTELS I THINK BRANDON CAN
ATTEST TO THAT OR THE HUMAN
ENTRAPPING ORGANIZATIONS, IT IS
WIDE OPEN.
OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS THEIR
HANDS HAVE BEEN TIED BEHIND
THEIR BACKS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
THEY ONCE HAD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN BASICALLY UNDER
TURNED EVERY'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
PUT IN PLACE BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME AND MY
TIME COVERING THE BORDER THAT I
ACTUALLY SAW ACTION BEING TAKEN
ON THE BORDER THAT WAS ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE WHERE PEOPLE REMAINED
IN MEXICO, WHERE PEOPLE WERE
ABLE TO BE RETURNED BACK, OR TH
DRUG CARTEL IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS KNEW THIS WAS THE
END OF THE ROAD FOR THEM.
AS SOON AS PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME
INTO OFFICE HE ANNOUNCED THE
BORDER WOULD BE OPEN ONCE AGAIN.
JUST LAST MONTH 55,000 GOT A
WAYS GETTING INTO THE COUNTRIES.
THOSE WE'RE PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T
APPREHENDED.
OVER 800,000 SINCE PRESIDENT
BIDEN CAME INTO OFFICE?
THAT'S UNHEARD OF.
ANOTHER FACTOR.
>> SARAH, EXCUSE ME.
I'VE HEARD A LOT MORE THAN
800,000.
WE HAD 300,000 LAST MONTH.
>> ABSOLUTELY, BUT THAT IS KNOW
TO GOD WAYS.
THAT IS PEOPLE THEY KNOW HAVE
ESCAPED INTO THE COUNTRY IN
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, OR PRO
500 DEATHS JUST THIS YEAR ALONE
OF MIGRANTS, NOT EVEN INCLUDING
100,000 AMERICANS THAT HAVE DIE
OF DRUG OVERDOSE.
>> AS IT RELATES TO THAT.
THE UNITED NATIONS HAS ISSUED A
DECORATION DECLARATION THAT THE
DEADLIEST AREA IN THE WORLD IS
THE AREA BETWEEN FROM THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES TO
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY BASICALLY SAY THIS
MIGRATION STUDY DEEMS THE U.S.
MEXICAN BORDER OF THE DEADLIEST
LAND ROUTE AND THE WORLD BASED
ON THE 2021 NUMBERS.
THERE ARE NOT EVEN AT THE 2022
NUMBERS.
>> WE ARE THE GREATEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD AND YOU WOULD NEVE
KNOW IT BY THOSE FIGURES RIGHT
THERE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS COMPLETE
AND TOTAL CHAOS IN A DISREGARD
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
LET'S HOPE CONGRESS IS WILLING
TO STEP UP.
WE KNOW THIS ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T GOING TO DO IT.
WE NEED PEOPLE IN CONGRESS WHO
WOULD BE WILLING TO CLOSE
EVERYTHING, IF WE NEED TO GET
DONE, IF WE HAD THE PROPER
LEGISLATION WE COULD DO IT.
IF WE HAD POLICIES THIS WHITE
HOUSE WOULD GIVE HELICES LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
WE COULD CONTROL WHAT'S GOING ON
.
WE CAN'T DO IT UNDER THIS WHITE
HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
>> AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS
THE ONE THAT CAME UP WITH THIS
IDEA OF BASICALLY CREATING THIS
SITUATION WHERE A STATE CAN
ENGAGE IN DEFENSIVE ACTIONS NEA
THE BORDER CAUSED BY THESE
TRANSNATIONAL CARTELS AND GANGS.
>> 100 PERCENT, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
HAS BEEN SUED RIGHT NOW BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BASICALLY
SAYING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE IDS TO ACTUALLY
VOTE.
HE LIKES TO TAKE ME, TAKE ME TO
COURT.
LET'S GO TO THE SUPREME COURT
AND I AGREE WITH HIM.
AT THINK THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
GREATLY NEED MORE PEOPLE LIKE
HIM COME UP MORE PEOPLE THAT
IMPACT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MORE PEOPLE THAT OUR CHALLENGIN
THIS BECAUSE WE CAN DO IT.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST THE BORDER.
WE HAVE SO MUCH FENNEL POURING
ACROSS THAT BORDER IT'S COMING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT IS KILLING ARE YOUNG PEOPLE
IT IS KILLING OUR CITIZENS.
WE ALSO HAVE PEOPLE BEING
MIGRATED ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AN
THAT IS ON THE TAXPAYER DIME AN
IT IS A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE
WITH OVER 50 PEOPLE CONNECTED T
KNOWN TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WE HAVE APPREHENDED UP THA
BORDER.
THIS IS A SERIOUS CRISIS, ONE
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
THAT IS THEIR MAIN AUTHORITY TH
MAIN AUTHORITY GIVEN TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THE
PRESIDENT IS TO PROTECT U.S.
CITIZENS AND HE IS NOT DOING I